[Music]
let's go to chad and saint george man
hey chad
yeah how are we doing
we're doing good i'm glad to be honest
thanks man hey i drove through st george
last year on the way to a speaking
engagement
what a stunning
beautiful place
um i just continue the more i travel
across the country speaking to groups i
i am just blown away by how beautiful
this country is and that st george area
is something else man was stunning
stunning stunning and i almost died
that's another conversation all right so
what's up brother how can i help
uh okay so
i gotta give some backstory before i get
to my question or my advice
so
um
our father died uh the end of july oh
man i'm sorry what did he die of
uh
well it would be what you call your uh
long tail suicide oh no
basically drank and smoked himself into
he's not recovering
he started failing i'm sorry brother
that's hard and hard hard
it's really hard
um
so every right after that
um
my sister my younger sister she's two
years younger than me she's
i don't know if her if the drama
responds to these things or
her and her husband decided that they
are now going to be swingers heyo
um yeah just a swanging
i know so
at first nobody really cut it everyone
was just kind of like now this is just
midlife crisis kind of stuff or
let me pause you
[Music]
if my wife came to me and said hey john
i got an idea
what about you and me just start
knocking around with the neighbors you
in and i was like i'm in honey
the last people on planet earth i would
call is my brother and sister
so
how do you know that this
is happening and i'm not laughing at i'm
laughing with you like how would you
even know man did they announce this to
like a thanksgiving
they
this is kind of how she is she wants
she wanted the attention of it
um
and you know other people like we'll see
friends of our that i've known for years
middle school
or
all of a sudden they're friends and i
would have had no idea because they
don't advertise it but she does she
wants everyone to know
weird
yeah
okay i'm being super weird man i i love
my sister with all my heart and there's
just parts of her life i don't want to i
don't want to know about that's cool
right but you know about your sister all
right so how can i help man yes
so
um
in doing all this her she has a 12 year
old son my nephew okay freaking raddest
kid ever
um he
has kind of just been
i mean he is either locked in his room
when it happens
or
or he goes to other family members or
friends houses but now
everyone else has stopped taking him
because they feel like they're enabling
her to do this
or
when he's at their house he's saying he
wants to be at my house with my boys and
wife
so they're like well
so now i'm stuck in the middle of
do i i feel like
by taking him it enables her to do that
it doesn't she's gonna
dude chad chad she's gonna do it anyway
i know you're not enabling her that's
where
you
take her out of the equation
take her completely out of the equation
okay you're taking care of a little 12
year old boy that's
it all right okay and you're the kind of
you're the kind of guy that would take
care of a 12 year old boy because that's
who you are you're a good human being
you got your kids of your own you're a
guy who loves this community and loves
young people take care of that 12 year
old little boy you're not you're your
sister is going to figure out a way
around this until it burns itself out
and make no mistake it will it will lose
its smoke and steam and
the disco ball eventually stops spinning
right
and so
it is what it is
or that 12 year old boy is really really
close to independence on his own
right right and he y'all gonna all lose
him and so yeah somebody's got to love
that kid and care about him
yeah
okay
god can you imagine the book being
written in my head my mom locked me in
my room while she
hooked up with my dad's middle school i
mean my uncle's middle school friends
and my that's going to be a great a
great autobiography someday geez
freaking yeah
well the the weirdest part about this
whole thing is yeah tell me the weirdest
part because
so far
well the whole thing's weird but yeah
they're so they have an older son that's
22 23. he's my we have older sons and
they all kind of grew up and we took him
all the time too how old are you um
i'm 43. how old is your sister
she's
42.
i've had in my head this whole
conversation you were like 25.
this makes this whole thing way more
disturbing go ahead go ahead right just
like 40 year olds just cruising like
what's up all right so yeah all right so
they have an older older son okay yeah
there's an older son he's in his in the
early 20s um and
apparently
he is the one that suggested to them
that they do this
why not they let him into that part of
their life like why not i don't think
he's doing it with them but
to have that conversation
dude she already told her brother so why
not bring your kids in she probably sat
down all the pets just said them all in
a row and told them to
yeah
dude who knows who knows man i
um yeah a 22 year old had grown up and
he's old enough to have his own
boundaries and to make his own choices
and decisions it is what it is
um right yeah when my son's 22 we're
gonna well i mean i'll share everything
with my son but we're not talking about
that
because i love him you know what i mean
i don't know i want to melt him but
here's the thing man
you have to decide in your in your heart
and mind this me being serious now
um
the people you choose to associate with
and this is hard because she's your
sister
and
there's some point when she becomes not
your sister
but and i think i mean this we talk
about swinging and all that kind of
stuff and we can make jokes about it
this is bigger than that you've lost
your sister not just because she's
sleeping with other dudes and her
husband sleeps with other women that's
not it
um she is searching so hard
to be seen and to be known and to not
feel um dead in her own skin
that ways she can fire off firecrackers
underneath her own skin
to prop herself up is to go get her
heart rate racing for 30 minutes with a
stranger to
try to get a rise out of you and the
other family members look at me look at
me look at me look at me and that's a
little girl in that little body saying
somebody tell me tell me you love me
somebody see me right so the whole thing
is heartbreaking and it's easy to point
to the one thing that's like
swinging just because it sounds funny
right um but you could point to that but
this is a this is the story of a brother
who's losing his little sister
yeah right and that sucks and it's
heartbreaking
and it puts you in a position to say
here's my boundary
while you're trying to figure out love
this is what this is what connecting
with me looks like and if you want to
opt out i'm going to be heartbroken but
you're free to do that
because this is how i'm going to raise
my kids so i'm going to raise my family
this is how i'm going to fill in the
blank right right um
and by the way if she circles back and
joins the fold and
and i say that like with in it with a
smirk on my face like like if she
circles back and says hey dude i kind of
lost it and her and her husband she used
to still do this once a month they
should
i still wouldn't have a problem with her
eating dinner at my house it's my sister
my kids are all gonna know yep that's
that's aunt so-and-so
uh my kids call my sister uh tialoka
they don't know her name my sister gave
them that name that's spanish for a
crazy aunt they gave right like my kids
think that my sister's name is tia loka
so i mean we they just know like yeah
that's aunt so-and-so right they get
that um this is about i've got to draw
boundaries and my guess is she's talking
in ways that you don't want around your
kids you're worried about the fact that
she's locking her their 12 year old son
12 is old my son's 12 right locking this
kid that knows what's going on in this
house in his room
i mean that whole thing is a mess man
and so this is about a brother who's
losing his little sister this is about a
guy trying to take care of a 12 year old
kid let's take all the take all the big
flashy stuff and the signs and oh my
gosh and
take all that off the table man grieve
the loss of your sister come up with
your boundaries there and then love and
take care of this little 12 year old kid
and if it crosses over into hey she
locked him in there for a day
call cps
yeah
call the authorities because she can't
you can't lock it you can't lock a child
in a room and not give them food not
give them water all that kind of stuff
right yeah well he i don't i don't know
how many times that's happened but i do
know that like hey here's a xbox
have fun in there don't come out you
know right right right
and again that's different than i put a
padlock on the door while we're in here
and i'm going to put a padlock on the
door you can't come out there's
difference there right but
ultimately
you have to grieve the loss of your
sister
and
you have to make some choices am i going
to accept this new behavior am i going
to accept this new relationship that
she's put back that she's choosing to or
am i going to draw the boundaries for me
and my family and
how and when am i going to love this 12
year old little boy
and that's i wouldn't let any of the
other nonsense clouded okay it's just
gonna make it more complicated you can
also tell her
um
when she's like oh yeah and then last
weekend you can stop her
and say i do not want to hear about your
sexual exploits you're my sister stop
yeah don't give it any any attention
she'll say it and i just
she wants the attention i'm not giving
it to her well
but she can see your eye crinkles she
can feel the energy in the room change
and that's power that feels powerful
there's something about stopping that
conversation as it's happening with a
firm boundary
right stop stop talking about your sex
life with me i do not want to know
period and let that tension hang let
that because that is you reclaiming the
room energy that you recrea reclaiming
your boundaries and it changes the
dynamic of it oh my gosh you think
you're so much better than me didn't say
that i said stop talking about your sex
life with me period right and with that
level of authority and force and it has
a way of of really pushing back on
people who just like to lob fireworks
and grenades at people and be like oh
yeah look what i'm doing look what i'm
doing could care less
do not tell me that
if you continue to tell me that you are
choosing to not be in a relationship
with me and i hope you don't choose that
because i like hanging out with you
and now she owns all the cards moving
forward because you have put your
boundary in concrete right and that's an
awesome awesome thing it's a gift to her
brother and it's a gift to you and your
family thank you for being a guy that
takes care of the little kids in your
community and in your family it's
beautiful